foreign
this morning on the dish and sauce it's
short friends the Idaho family that
creates incredible chorizo inspired by
The Basque region of Spain Dan and
sadegi is a James Beard nominee who's
owned multiple restaurants in Boise his
latest was supposed to start as a
catering operation during covid but it's
become a sit-down dining destination an
authentic Taste of the old country in
the American West
here we go
[Music]
ever since the first Basque migrants
cross the Atlantic and arrived here in
the late 1800s to work the Sheep trade
the traditions of food music and culture
have been kept alive
[Music]
at the center of that Community today is
Dan and sadegi his accordion and his
authentic Cuisine most especially is
chorizo what do we do well we started
off here with our pork shoulder and
we've added some back fat we want to get
about that 65 percent lean to 35 percent
fat in violation of the age-old saying
and sadhi showed us exactly how the
sausage is made
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to add our whole garlic
paprika a little bit of Aleppo pepper
and salt as that's going this is just
white wine nice so we're getting some
moisture here and then this is the
chorizero pepper sauce
this is what makes a chorizo chorizo for
Spanish and best people smells good
we're halfway there then in came the
stuffing machine we're just kind of
bringing this up and we're going to just
add it
right in there
you want to make sure we don't have any
air pockets
then what we're doing is we're basically
putting this entire mount on there
so now the next thing we're going to do
is is rather fun you're just going to
go ahead and rotate at a comfortable
speed and it'll just start coming out
and we want a little bit of resistance
not much just a tiny bit how's my speed
it's just fine
so here we go and we just measure it
like this and we just kind of pinch it
here and oh and turn it okay it gives us
our length
then the next one we're going to do the
same thing and we're going to go the
opposite way oh okay
and Sonic still makes his chorizo the
same way his grandma Epi did from a
recipe passed down over the generations
she was in command in the kitchen she
started as a seamstress came over as a
very young lady married my grandfather
and had to learn how to cook really
quick and sadegi eventually traveled to
Basque country to learn more and has run
three restaurants in Boise the latest is
called ansats my cooking came out of
that desire to eat well and to eat those
have those flavors that I remembered
growing up how did Boise become such a
Bastion for Basque culture so there's a
little bit of the history is a little
bit like the Irish in the sense that
poverty drove the Irish and poverty
drove Basque people to leave but why
Boise Boise happened to be the largest
town in the area had the most boarding
houses so the most bass people came here
and so when they finished hurting they
often stayed in those towns where they
were getting used to and getting getting
to know people
[Music]
a Basque Festival of food and arts
called high Aldi is held every five
years in Boise bringing in 30 000 people
from around the world and the City Sites
include a basque Museum and multiple
restaurants and shops
in 2019 and sadegi was named a cultural
heritage fellow by the National
Endowment for the Arts
and sots has grown from its initial
Vision as a catering operation pushed
Along by Dan's daughter Ellie what has
this place been like for you it's been
super interesting just because we
started during covid so it was kind of
just like constant fear of if we would
make it or not it was my first like real
profession because before I've always
worked at restaurants worked at my
aunt's restaurant but I was like the bus
or girl and so now I had to take on
leadership
[Applause]
for the insertegies the family business
goes beyond making traditional Basque
food
to making traditional Basque music
[Music]
[Applause]
what is it about the accordion nobody
really knows if you're doing it right
[Music]
right it's kind of uh um they're like I
think that's pretty good I don't know
that's it that's all we know when it was
finally time to eat the table was
stuffed
a charcuterie board it's difficult to
find much charcuterie in The Basque
Country charcuterie really we see that
in other parts of Europe especially
Italy but I love charcuterie however I
don't like a lot of the Italian spices
so what I wanted to do was take
charcuterie but present it with Basque
flavors calamari that was plump and
extra meaty a BLT and egg sandwich
and the chorizo this is the one that we
patterned we're on recipe number 19
right now
yeah because we were trying our very
best to get to Grandma eppies chorizo
casing is a little bit crispy and that
comes partially from the time that it
hangs I mistakenly called it a sausage
earlier but it is it is a chorizo is a
sausage okay so I can say that sure also
mixed Croquettes eggs in purgatory
paella with sausage clams mussels and
chicken
a burnt Basque cheesecake
and a sugary caramelized croissants
called Queen among
so it's oh wow correctly it's dense but
I've also never been trained so I kind
of just throw things in the oven and be
like I hope it worked
pretty good
I hope it works
[Laughter]
why is it so important for you to keep
bass culture alive in Boise I don't know
how often I actually think about
something like that food makes me happy
I get to try things and flavors and just
like okay that that's really going
somewhere and and so when we're doing
things that make us happy and and make
other people happy I feel like we're
going the right direction
and we want to thank the insatis for
sending us this wonderful spread all the
way from Idaho dig in please
ask meatballs and salsa Espanola clams
and matsac salt Cod and Spanish cured
ham
um chorizo
plates the chorizo I think was the spicy
one I had that was right the spicy one
yeah it was really good
um and the charcuterie board which is
House made and what's really cool is
there's a house made charcuterie there
with Squid Ink like the black black yeah
really cool and and these both are Cod
um one is cod and one is the mixed
Cricket I believe we'll keep eating good
stuff